we just actually want to ask her what we  can do and what our involvement should  be what Hollywood's involvement could be  and what the United States should be  doing as well and probably and ask her  about her you know the difficulties that  she's facing I think it's an important  time to be talking about these things do  you agree with her policy well you know  I absolutely agreed with it in the  beginning of course it was an amazing  policy if she's facing a lot of  difficulties you know there's a million  refugees here that's a big task and and  it becomes a politically heavier as time  goes on so you're hoping to encourage  that sort of behavior because it was  such a you know it's been sort of the  beacon you know in the in the rest of  Europe particularly you know so yes do  you think we should all be doing well if  a United States needs to do more as we  know you know 10,000 refugees a year is  not enough that's that's clear